ماذا استنتجت من هذه الصور التي حصلنا
عليها حصلت عليها الجزيره
للاشتباكات الدائره و تمكن المقاومه
واستمرارها في استمرار تمكنها في استهداف
جيش الاحتلال في داخل
القطاع يعني هذا اختلس له علاقه باولا
طبيعه المقاتلين كفاءتهم القتاليه
الميدانيه المعنويات الشجاعه الاستبسال
طبيعه الارض ايضا تربه خصبه يعني
للمقاومين الفلسطينيين خاصه الركام الذي
حاول الجيش الاسرائيلي ان يسخره لصالحه
والان الركام يقاتل مع المقاتلين اي
الجندي الاسرائيلي الجندي الاسرائيلي لا
يعرف ولا يعلم لا يعرف طبيعه الارض ولا
يعلم معلومات عن المقاومين وخاصه انه
الحرب الان حرب غير منظوره بالنسبه للجنود
الاسرائيليين في حين ان الجنود
الاسرائيليين منظورين من قبل المقاومين
لذلك امكانيه يعني اقتناصه اصطيادهم نصب
افخاخ نصب كمائن لهم بالنسبه للمقاومين
شيء رائع المعركه معركه فدائيين وليست
معركه جيوش وخاصه انه المناطق المبنيه
والضيقه لا تعطي الجنود الاسرائيليين
مناوره بالاليات وبد بابات ولكن المقاومين
الفلسطينيين يستغلوها يستغلوها بالمناور
بالحركه بقدرتهم على استخدام عنصر
المباغته والمفاجاه لانه معروف حرب حروب
المدن هي تحتاج الى فن قتال ا والجنود
الاسرائيليين غير مدربين على فنون القتال
في حروب المدن صحيح انهم تدربوا ولكن لا
يكفي كما هو المقاتلين الفلسطينيين
المقاتلين حروبهم حروب فدائيه بمعنى
مجموعات صغيره متحركه تستخدم نقاط قوتها
مقابل نقاط ضعف العدو تفاجئ العدو لا
يتوقعه العدو من من اي جهه سيخرج له
المقاتل ايضا المشاهد التي رايناها لواء
واصف ماذا تقول لنا
عن استمرار استخدام الانفاق في وقت يقول
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان عملياته في هذه
المرحله تركز على تدمير
الانفاق يعني واضح انه الجيش الاسرائيلي
يعتبر انه الانفاق هدف استراتيجي بالنسبه
له اذا ما تم اكتشافه انا اعتقد انه هناك
نوعين من الانفاق نوع رب ما هو النوع
القديم الذي يعرفه العدو الاسرائيلي في
المعارك السابقه وفي جمع المعلومات
الامنيه والاستخباري السابقه وهناك نوع من
الانفاق اعتقد انها محدثه لا يعرف عنها
العدو الاسرائيلي وهي التي يبرع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في استخدامها هو يحاول الوصول
اليها ولكن يحاول من خلال جمع المعلومات
لذلك نراه يعتقل عدد كبير من الشباب
والفتيات والرجال من اجل جمع المعلومات عن
هذه الانفاق وهناك طبعا يعني سخر كل
امكانياته الجويه والارضيه والرقابه
والسيطره والروبوتات وكل الوسائل التقنيه
الحديثه من اجل الاكتشاف هذه الانفاق
ولكنه حتى الان لم يكتشفها بدليل ان
المقاومين الفلسطينيين يستخدمونها بطريقه
يعني اذهلت العدو الاسرائيلي اي ال ال
يعني الحرب حقيقه بالنسبه للجنود
الاسرائيليين غير متكافئه مع المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين وخاصه في قضيه الامن
والاستخبارات ومعرفه طبيعه الارض
والمعلومات الامنيه وقدرات المقاومه وخاصه
المعلومات عن الانفاق هم دائما وابدا
يبحثون عن هذه الانفاق لذلك نراهم احيانا
يتمدد يحاولوا تعميق تقدمهم في مناطق
معينه ثم ينسحبون منها ويعطون هذه المهمه
ل مدفعيه المدفعيه البريه او لسلاح الجو